what's up y'all
movie retrospective yeah this is a
classic
i'm really really happy that you guys
chose this one like the patreon people
than the vote because i put it in the
vote
because i bought these for uh for tom
for christmas
yeah and then i was like oh please oh
please oh please i was like let them
so thankfully i didn't even cheat like
you know what i mean like everybody did
vote for them so um these are
we're gonna be talking about psycho
one through four yeah it's blu-ray let
me show you let me show them too
it's got a slip cover clear plastic
it was a great set looks really good so
i'll give you a review just on
on the on the quality remaster is really
good i say the only thing
that we could not afford or didn't come
with any extras there are
literally zero extras on any of them
even the original psycho there's no uh
commentary track there's no trailers
there's nothing
i thought there would be extras but
there wasn't um i saw i've seen all
these movies
most of them i forgot all right i always
i always remember the first one
yeah but going back and seeing them man
they stand up to the test of time they
were
all you know the first one's hard to
beat because you know it's alfred
hitchcock it's ground breaking horror
but the rest of them you know anthony
perkins is involved in all three of them
i think he
directed all three no he directed the
third one just the third one yeah and
they're they're all they're all real
good i would say that
this series
compares very favorably to the phantasm
series in terms of just like quality and
world building and
the theme behind it you know yeah
because it just seems good
all i mean all of them are it'd be hard
for me to rank them but all of them are
worth watching
and all of them bring something a little
bit different to the
mythology of it which i think is kind of
cool usually
you know you get two good movies and
then movie three sucks
you know yeah and then the chances there
being a movie four being any good
very like next to nothing but in this
one
like phantasm every movie is very strong
real strong movie
and i yeah and i had forgotten how good
they actually all were because we
watched them
i guess over two nights i think we
watched part one and part two and then
the next day we watched like three and
four or something like that
um so yeah so we've watched them all
recently i will say
i think that well actually i'm almost
positive that i saw
psycho 2 before i saw the first one like
i was aware of the first one
but i and i had seen bits of it but i
had never sat like
through the whole thing like straight
through but
um so so i i really really liked part
two and then later on i went back when i
was a little bit older and saw
the first one i saw psycho one in the
70s as a little kid when i was in
california they played it on tv
and it tripped me out it must have been
probably about eight seven or eight when
i watched it and liked it
so it was it was because i liked the
twilight zone by that
time yeah and it kind of reminded me of
a long twilight zone
episode and uh i had i knew nothing
about it
about the mom or being stuffed or
anything i didn't know anything about it
and spoiler alert
whoa so i kind of i kind of had a uh
it was kind of like seeing it you know
because because i didn't know anything
about it
i the way i experienced it would have
been the way the audience experienced it
and was at 19
in 1960 yeah came out because not
knowing anything and uh
no i liked it man it's really good which
that's kind of a bummer it's like i
don't i wouldn't want to go back in time
to 1960 because it sucked in a lot of
other ways but
i i really wish that i had been able to
see
the first psycho without knowing what
was gonna happen
because i mean by the time you know the
80s rolled around when i ended up seeing
the first one everybody knew
like all the plot points in this [ __ ]
but it you know
you have to think too like how [ __ ]
groundbreaking this movie was i mean
we've done we talked about peeping tom
uh directed by michael powell which uh
came out the same year as psycho
actually came about
out about five months before if i'm
remembering correctly and i feel like
that
um was real significant in the kind of
development of the slasher genre but
this one was obviously much better known
than that one
even though this is less like a slasher
than peeping thomas
but you have to think the the [ __ ] that
alfred hitchcock got for this movie well
for one thing
um they didn't want him to really make
it um
he you know obviously and if you didn't
know it's based on a novel
by robert block which uh which he kind
of based on ed gein a little bit
um you know but kind of you know
fictionalized it and alfred hitchcock
liked it so much that he ended up he
went to the studio and they were just
like yeah no we don't want to make that
we
they thought it was too lurid i guess or
it was
trashy or whatever little did they know
i know yeah that's the thing and so
alfred hitchcock was like well [ __ ] you
then i'll
buy the rights to the novel myself and
the only reason that the only way that
they would let him make it
is if they made it in black and white
which was cheaper because obviously in
1960 you know there were some black and
white movies being made but most people
were making [ __ ] in color by that time
he's like i'll make it in black and
white we'll make it with the same crew
and on a lot of the same sets as the
alfred hitchcock presents show
um which i [ __ ] loved growing up yeah
i remember seeing it was good
yeah and uh he's like so you know then
then we'll let you do it now it's funny
because when it came out
it's really strange in hindsight
when you know the movie is a classic to
the extent that psycho
is a classic if anything is and it is so
penetrated the you know the popular
culture even kids nowadays know what the
[ __ ] you know when somebody makes that
noise like the stabbing noise and the
mom dress up
everybody knows what that is and so it's
funny to
read contemporary reviews of it
some of the reviews of it were good but
a lot of them were like real mixed or
real negative
a lot of people thought oh it's too
violent it was like i said real trashy
or like it wasn't classy like not up to
alfred hitchcock's usual uh high
standards
you know it was too sordid um
i know because it's like because all of
these things that were in it
you know very famously it was i think it
was the first uh mainstream uh hollywood
american movie
that showed a toilet um and actually
showed a toilet flushing shoes yeah
toilets aren't supposed to exist
we're not supposed to show them and the
funny thing about it is to take showers
i know and the funny thing is that i had
forgotten but the
the trailer for psycho had alfred
hitchcock in it like talking about and
he was in the room and he stood in front
of the toilet and like pointed down in
it and it's like you know they flush
them
because you know it's a plot point in
the movie that she tears up that thing
with the
with the money amount on it and flushes
it down the toilet and they show it in a
close-up
um also the fact that one of the very
first scenes
is janet leigh and her uh
hunk of man meet and they're like in a
bedroom
they're not married and she has a bra
and they're like
they're in the same bed which was really
in a really in a rented room
controversial well that's that was great
though that was that was groundbreaking
because
you weren't supposed to do that they
yeah right in the face oh no we're going
to go there
this is the way the [ __ ] really is yeah
you know what i mean they're they're not
married and they're
they're [ __ ] getting it on yeah
another thing that in the very beginning
that
surprised me is that the theme song i'm
looking at and i'm going
that is the theme song to [ __ ]
herbert west reanimator well yeah that's
that herman wrestler
animator is that same damn song they
just extend you
accentuated a couple things a little bit
more and added a few notes
to get that
[Music]
that's going on underneath i think it
sounds like a clarinet or something or
an oboe
going underneath the dam you know
it says man it's herbert west it's hurt
the reanimator i mean
ripped it off directly well yeah but
they didn't really make a secret about
that that's what they were doing they
were doing like a parody
of it sort of but yeah the original is
great too it is
yeah and then then uh it opens up with
like
a girl committing a crime she's stealing
some money there's inner dialogue when
she's
paranoid you know the cops are on her
tail and just great you know
you know that was yeah it's very morally
gray yeah
because she's kind of like i mean she
was the biggest star in the movie
yeah um and that was kind of one of the
things like alfred hitchcock didn't want
anybody um he wouldn't let anybody into
the theaters
um you know like later you couldn't go
in late you had to go at the beginning
uh and he was really he wouldn't let uh
critics see it ahead of time
like so there wouldn't be any spoilers
leaking out into the media and [ __ ] like
that because
he didn't want anyone to know that janet
lee the biggest star in the film like
dies like halfway through the movie
maybe not even halfway
yeah um so he's like well i don't want
people coming and seeing the last part
of the film and not seeing janet lee and
feeling like ripped off or whatever
but he also didn't want to spoil the
surprise because that was something
that was not done i mean not only was
janet lee playing
as i said a morally gray character who
you know was [ __ ] her person though
yeah but she was still deep down a good
person but she embezzled this money
yeah um you know it's obviously she
shouldn't have done it but
you couldn't blame her she was gonna
give it back eventually yeah
but you gotta watch the movie then
there's like another thing that was
weird is that when norman
comes into the into the picture he's
kind of like this
he he's a weird guy he he seems nice but
he's kind of like um
sexually ambiguous you're not really
sure you know is this guy straight or is
he gay what's the deal and then has the
story
and early on he's kind of like already
talking weird about his mom so it's kind
of like insinuating that there's some
kind of an
unnatural it's hinting like a damn
you know a an incestuous relationship
with the mom
and the and i think the janet lee
characters just pic was picking up on
that
yeah there was something to some kind of
sexual abuse going on which that's
[ __ ] in 1960 that [ __ ] was just
over the [ __ ] that was just through
the roof it's interesting
too because anthony perkins was
specifically cast in this
because he was being cast against type
at the time
that psycho was made in 1960 anthony
perkins had been
you know in some stage plays and he'd
been in some films and tv and stuff
but he was primarily known as being kind
of like the handsome boy next door type
um so that's why alfred hitchcock wanted
him so bad yeah he's like because i
wanted somebody with that kind of
boyish vulnerable quality to be
the killer yeah um and he's not really
into
he he seems like he's not really into
women he's just into his mom and
it's like there's there's no sec so you
go wait hold on what's going on here
and kind of the way he walks and the way
his mannerisms are kind of
you know i mean feminine almost kind of
like almost kind of like a
you know like like a twink you know i'm
gonna say he's kind of a twink you know
but uh no that's not what the deal was
it's just it was just it's just playing
with you
the movie's [ __ ] with your mind and i
think back in 1960s it would have really
[ __ ] with you
oh yeah and that's where they're getting
off with all this all this [ __ ] seedy
and trashy because they'll let all those
subjects would have been considered
trashy
yeah they wouldn't like exploitation
yeah more than serious but no it's
it's a [ __ ] masterpiece is what it is
and it gave
birth it gave rise eventually to the
slasher movies
yeah that's where this came from this
and peeping tom were definitely like the
big
no we don't we're not going to review
each movie in in you know
in detail [ __ ] we're going to talking
about all fours
just like in a loose sort of way movie 2
is real strong
it's a strong comeback it's every bit as
good as
as movie one it's a it's a real good
response to it
um and you can definitely see that it's
like
that you're dealing with basically a
slasher movie it's just it's not as
there's not as many kills in it it's not
really reveling in it
as much as say like friday the 13th but
it has like a
an expensive friday an expensive
well-written friday the 13th
feel to it you know that somebody's
throat could get slashed or something
you know what i mean really liked a
movie too and uh
anthony perkins first really not he
knocks it out of the park in every movie
he's good in every one of these movies
yeah i will say
that as as i said he was kind of on the
cusp of stardom when they made the first
one
and he was kind of it seemed like he was
going more
along the career path of as i said
playing kind of boyish you know
boy next door types and then when he did
psycho
he started immediately getting type cast
as now he
always plays like a crazy person or or
like a nice dude with a
sinister secret or something like he
always played that there's another one
he did that i thought was awesome it was
called what was the edge of
edge of sanity yeah we got to see that
one too i was looking for that one the
other day because i saw it a bunch on
cable back i remember liking it
but he got i guess like for a time he
was he talked about getting typecast and
he's like yeah it kind of sucked but
he's like if i had to go back and do it
again i would still do it it's like yeah
it sucks being typecast but
he's like what made his name on that
though yeah these are legendary movies
especially the first one just
that was groundbreaking now what i liked
about the second one
um i kind of feel like they were
they were thinking about i think they
were thinking about doing a sequel to
psycho
well you know it was kind of one of
those ideas people threw around i don't
know if hitchcock really liked the idea
or anything like that
but he died in 1980 alfred hitchcock did
so then they decided well okay we're
gonna kind of um
we'll get on board with this because
robert block who wrote the original
novel
had actually written a novel called
psycho two
but when the the people like the
producers who were thinking about doing
a sequel when they read the book they
hated it because they're like look
basically the book i haven't read it but
i read like a synopsis of it
what the book psycho two is is basically
like a parody it's almost like
making fun of the first movie and making
fun of the slasher genre
you know what i mean yeah so it's it's
almost like a black comedy type of thing
and the producers like no man we don't
want to do that we want to make like a
horror movie it's like a continuation
um even though it's this many years
later so they just said [ __ ] it we just
want a whole new thing
so they got the guy that wrote it tom
holland
uh actually went on much later and much
more famously
to direct fright night child's play
several other uh movies in that regard
so he was still like out of a young
writer at this point
now the guy that directed the second one
was richard franklin who was an
australian dude and he was actually a
protege of alfred hitchcock and knew
everything about
hitchcock knew everything about all his
films he had worked with him on several
things
he also made um kind of a very
well-regarded australian film called
road games which we should probably
review one of these days because it is
wrong
yeah yeah i think i've seen it as well
so he was the one that did the second
one
and i really really like so it seemed
like when they were making
the sequel that it that was what was
good about it it wasn't just a cash grab
you know what i'm saying it's like the
because it was like 22 23 years later
that they made it because it came out in
1983
and it's weird because at first when
they were talking about doing it anthony
perkins they asked him hey do you want
to be norman bates again
and initially he didn't want to do it
they were actually going to get
christopher walken
um which still would have worked i think
yeah but there's nothing like the
original though yeah because it's
because it's exactly like he's that
person it's the same dude and then like
you know 22 years later
he gets let out of the mental asylum
anthony
made this character in the same way that
you know
[ __ ] nimoy made spock
yeah yeah this character is his
character
you know just he created it you can tell
yeah i mean i think the movie still
would have been okay if
um if someone else had been in the role
but i i think there's really no
replacement
yeah for anthony yeah after two movies
had the third one
if the other two didn't have him in it
they would they would have bombed but
this is one of those rare exceptions
where all four movies were very good at
least very good
yeah i mean the second one really
totally should not have worked
but it did work i think the writing was
really good the acting was really good
um there was some [ __ ] where it's
interesting too because i was watching
this big long retrospective on the
second one because like i said the
second was the first one i saw so that
was like my entry
into the psycho series they were talking
about
meg tilly who's in it and uh her and
anthony hopkins did not get along
um meg tilly did not really know
anything about psycho she hadn't seen
the original movie
and um she was uh kind of an
inexperienced because she was you know
very new to
to acting and everything and i guess she
got butthurt because he was like giving
her acting tips and
he was real exacting about because it
was his character and it was kind of you
know his story and whatnot
so she was getting kind of annoyed about
that initially and here's another thing
i didn't know
they didn't want they were thinking
about getting jamie lee curtis for that
role
oh that had been good too though but
then they were like well she might be
too familiar
because of halloween and because she was
in so many other horror movies and it's
like
we want somebody that's a little less
recognizable two is very much
in in on par with with halloween
i think so as well very much on par with
halloween they're all good all the way
up to movie four and you would think by
the time movie ford rolled around like
nah you can't keep doing this but no
they did it
like i said i like that they did
something different with each one
because i mean the second one
you know if you haven't seen the second
one basically you know norman's been in
an asylum
yeah this whole time for 22 years he's
let out
and um they got the original uh actress
that played uh vera miles that played
lila
um the sister of you know janet lee's
character in the original
so they got her to come back and she's
like having a [ __ ]
fit there he's out about norman getting
out because he's like to the same house
in the same hotel and he's trying to
[ __ ] integrate into society
yeah and what's funny is that norman
threw all these movies
in a weird way norman's the good guy
he's he's actually the good guy i mean
he's not a good guy because he's a
murderer but he's sympathetic
yeah he's doing well some of that [ __ ]
he doesn't know he's doing it
yeah some of it he did nobody's he was
trying to defend his mom in his mind
weird [ __ ]
it's it's just it's a good story
in in movie two though he's the good guy
yeah he actually doesn't
well until the very end when he kills
somebody but
you kind of think he had been pushed
over the edge by that point right it
wasn't really his fault it wasn't really
his fault so
it was just a good event what i do like
about it is that
at the end of movie four
the character was redeemed yeah he's he
was he's eventually redeemed which that
was good he
it had a real good story arc to to
to norman bates yeah i mean i liked that
they did
one thing i wanted to mention while we
were talking about the first movie that
i think is really funny that i don't
that obviously you wouldn't have to put
in a movie today i like at the end of
the first movie they have to have that
psychiatrist come in and explain
yeah they mansplain the [ __ ] about you
know oh he had like a
you know another personality like
dissociative
identity disorder as they would call it
nowadays and he dressed up in his
mother's clothes because somebody asked
is he a transvestite they're like no
not really he's just taking another
that's not the same thing so i thought
that was really funny
i mean that was another thing that was
probably really controversial for 1960
but it's funny that they had to explain
that to audiences because now everybody
knows like what that [ __ ] is and they're
like oh yeah i gotcha
and then another thing you see
mansplaining in movies man is playing in
white's playing
whatever you want to call it that was
[ __ ] that was big in 50s movies
these movies you need an authority
figure to come in and [ __ ] explain to
you what it was
explain to the audience yeah that goes
back to [ __ ] ed wood
ed ed wood would [ __ ] mansplain
all his because that's how he fleshed
out his stories he did yes playing to
you
but uh please didn't tell you to trust
the government
that well that's how that's how he got
away with putting really really worried
stuff into his movies yeah
is because he's like well it's a warning
to people like hey don't get sucked up
into porn don't get sucked into this but
so he's showing all right
but but once again [ __ ] um you know
once again once again that psycho knocks
uh [ __ ]
puts a different riff on it did you
notice that the dude the authority
figure that's explaining to you what it
was you just saw
did you notice that he was hispanic
oh yeah yeah that was probably kind of
unusual for that time
i was going to be a white guy yeah who
was the doctor who was going to explain
some [ __ ] to you
because of course he's going to know
better because white people know
everything yeah
that's just the thinking of the 60s you
know i mean the 50s in the 60s you know
put some white doctor up there to tell
us like what happened
no one will believe it if it doesn't
come from yeah
but they had a hispanic guy up there man
i was like oh okay man [ __ ] yeah
they're cutting edge
this is a cutting edge it was really i
mean this is this is a boundary breaking
film in a lot of ways and i was and
seeing it again because i haven't seen
it for many years and when we watched it
again the other day i was like wow i
forgot now i mean obviously it's not
controversial now
but i'm just saying putting yourself
back into the mindset of 1960.
i'm sure of like people but the thing
about it is that audience
audiences [ __ ] loved it there were
like lines around the [ __ ]
block i would have loved to see that
[ __ ] i would have loved it especially
back in 1960
oh yeah i saw it in the photo everybody
70s as a little kid and it was still it
you can watch it now and it still holds
together
oh yeah and and like i said i i think
it's still even
you know horror fans that are young
they're in their 20s
that still comes up in like their top 20
horror another thing is that
what i did like about the writing in the
old in the old ones is that their
confident
a weird mixture of a documentary slash
twilight zone everything is very clear
yeah you know what i mean the dialogue
is very clear the story points are very
clear
what it's trying to tell you is very
clear and then there's a very clear
subtext
it does there are things that it doesn't
say but it
let you know yeah they let you know they
didn't say that there was an incestuous
relationship going on
but you had to have known it implied
yeah it very very heavily implied
yeah and in movie four it's kind of um
yeah it's not kind of it's just like
what the deal was you know it doesn't
actually show
sex but almost but there's some pretty
weird [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
and then when you see the way the way
his weird ass mom was when she was young
and everything
and she wasn't a rotten old corp she was
you know young good looking when
this was going on and uh which kind of
made some of the stuff
made more sense she kind of had kind of
a mysterious accent where was she from
well that's olivia hussey she is [ __ ]
man
is that her real accent yeah that's how
she talks okay so she she's been in tons
of people she's kind of kind of italian
or something
i can't remember where she's from yeah
she does have a really weird [ __ ]
she's probably most famous for being she
was in uh romeo and juliet like
back in the [ __ ] year was that when
she was real young um but she's been in
[ __ ]
but um yeah so she was a psycho she she
was the psycho really the mom was the
psycho
yeah when when norman was young she's a
psycho
and they're living in that house by
themselves and she's [ __ ] sent us
some mixed ass signals to him and [ __ ]
him up
yeah well like i said i kind of like
that
you know throughout the whole series as
i said they make norman bates i mean
he's clearly
got problems yeah but they do portray
him sympathetically not in a way that
excuses what he does he's just mentally
ill but you understand
like why he does and you kind of feel
sorry for him because i like that
even in the first one they treated him
kind of sympathetically
even though he killed a lot of people
and that's bad but they
you know they said there was a reason
for him doing it in the second one
well in the first one and then well
actually in almost all of them if you
actually were to do the body count
technically it's not him well
technically it's him but he doesn't
realize it's him yeah it's his mom
yeah he thinks his mom's doing it yeah
so there's only one no there was
only two that he killed in his own
own guys there was only two yeah one in
the
at the end of the second one and one in
the third one was that the third one
yeah
that guy was gonna kill him probably
yeah that that you could argue is maybe
self-defense yeah
[Laughter]
well the guy was gonna kill him because
he realized that norman thought it was
his mom but this guy knew that it wasn't
his mom that was him so yeah
but norman couldn't couldn't accept that
it was him
killing these women yeah he thought it
was his mom yeah because like i said he
dissociated yeah yeah yeah
but yeah and the second one he didn't i
like that they made him they it
you know the movie was actually very i
mean for 1983 was very sympathetic with
you know how he had this terrible mental
illness but he'd been in the asylum he'd
worked through all the stuff with his
doctor
they were letting him back out and he
goes back to the house he gets a job you
know they help him out
and a lot of the people in town like the
cop and everything like that
are sympathetic to me like man leave him
alone you know he's done his time it's
like you know it sucks it's shitty what
he did but it's
you know it's over now is a long time
ago and the fact that
uh lila uh and the daughter
played by meg tilly mary the fact that
they are conspiring
to make him go crazy again because they
want him to be locked up again
um kind of pushes him over the edge then
so that's not really his fault because
those two [ __ ] were i mean
i don't want to say because meg tilly
character mary she actually does feel
bad about it
and then tells the mom hey knock it the
[ __ ] off but then some people are
getting killed and i like for a long
time you're
they leave it kind of ambiguous as to
who's killing all these people because
you're like i'm pretty sure
norman's not doing that [ __ ] but uh then
they find out like later who it is doing
it
and it's some other old bat that says no
i'm your real mom and all this stuff and
norman kills her
but she was a murderer too so
yeah i don't know that's kind of a wash
i think
[Laughter]
he's trying to get rid of evil yeah i
suppose now
now the third one um he actually does go
back into
uh into the whole psycho thing whereas
he's dressing up as his mom and killing
people
and this one this one's really
interesting i feel like
when i watch other people's reviews of
this the third one usually comes out on
the bottom like most people say you know
they're
you know they're all good but if you had
to rank them a lot of people don't like
the third one just because
the third one is just more of that yeah
i think about it
because it's more like a standard
slasher film
more of that um because you definitely
have
you know you have the weird nun
character that's played by that chick
that was in mommy dearest
um you know and and she comes there and
then
like he like he thinks that she looks
like marion crane because she's got kind
of the same hair and she looks kind of
like her and she has the same initials
or whatever
so he starts like phasing out and like
thinking that this is
her and that she's back from the dead or
like back to haunt him or whatever
and um and then some weird kind of [ __ ]
happens where
where this chick the nun she
ran away from the um from the convent
like after she
sort of accidentally she was gonna kill
herself and then she accidentally
knocked this other [ __ ] nun off of
the [ __ ] bell tower
splattered or whatever so it's like she
took off or they kicked her out or
whatever
and then she ends up in the hotel after
getting a ride from this rapey
[ __ ] who uh
he's gonna be a rock star who yeah what
was his name dwayne duke or something
uh played by jeff fahey which i love
that character i thought that character
is cool yeah he was
he was a scumbag but yeah it was he was
a good character he fit right in with
that movie
he did yeah and so she ends up going to
the motel
and interestingly norman's gonna kill
her
but then she's already like beat him to
the punch i guess because she like slit
her wrists and she's laying there in the
tub
and she's so she's kind of like bleeding
out and everything and she sees him
standing there with all the
woman [ __ ] on and with all the knife and
everything and she thinks it's the
virgin mary
so she starts to think that norman saved
her you know what i mean
so then he's like well obviously i can't
kill her now but then they kind of start
hooking up but then like i said jeff
fahey's character dwayne who's also kind
of a rapey [ __ ]
he figures out he gets a job there
because he's on his way to la and he
needs money or whatever
and um so he figures out what's going on
with norman and the corpse and
everything so he
is basically going to blackmail norman
yeah so like i said
and they kind of get him out of the out
of the land and uh
the hotel and stuff yeah so it's like
thousands of times really
he was not really i mean i didn't really
feel bad that he no he's a feeling
yeah i mean i'm not saying that you can
just go around like killing people all
the time but
and he and norman actually did in the
guise of his mother in the third one
did actually kill a few people that um
yeah and each that were innocent victims
like one girl that
got kicked out of uh duane's room and
all this other kind of [ __ ] yeah and
then each one of these movies the police
take
take a roll too there's always a cop and
there's always the town
the town and the cop yeah that always
play a role in the movie they're just
good movies you know just
it it's a really good series
each movie is very strong even the
weakest one which is three is still
pretty strong
and anthony perkins actually directed
that one yeah and the cinematography on
that one i think the cinematography on
that one is the nicest
the only reason why i think three was a
little bit weaker
it kind of doesn't it comes out more
towards the bottom is just that
it's it's kind of a continuation of two
really it's just kind of like more of
that
yeah it's just more blood more of that
yeah and it's more characters
yeah but you know that's not how you
would have that's not how you would have
perceived the movie at the time it
could had you had waited four or five
years for that [ __ ] to come out
because you'd have been waiting for it
to come out oh man part three's out
let's see that
you know what i mean so when you're
watching them back to back you see
they're kind of similar in some ways
yeah um part four it
went straight up kind of almost action
movie but i liked it
like action horror it was it was
constantly something happened but it had
us it still had that
psychological element of all the other
psycho movies it's all about
somebody's mind being [ __ ] up it's
doing flashbacks it's showing
what the mom the mom and and and the boy
were like when they were young
um just good movie you know i think four
four ended it pretty pretty damn well i
don't think that could be ended
any better what i don't think there's a
better way yeah i mean psycho for the
beginning if i remember correctly and
somebody please correct me if i'm wrong
i'm pretty sure that was made for cable
tv i don't think that got a theatrical
release which is kind of a shame
really um but yeah that was actually
that was actually quite a good movie i
saw it a lot like back on the table
in it though didn't it yeah so it must
have been made for cable
yeah because yeah it was made for tv tv
you couldn't put all that [ __ ] in there
but um because there was some [ __ ] in
there that yeah you couldn't put on
network tv for sure that was about what
did he say 1990
1990 1990 and that was like uh
on par with like that would have been
considered like a a pretty big budget
horror movie for 1990
oh yeah and it's definitely better than
a lot of other ones that i saw that came
out that year
yeah but yeah so basically i mean the
frame story is
that norman um he was
uh now he was incarcerated for a time
right after
uh the events of part three and then he
was let out again or he was on probation
right he was on probation he had since
married uh he ended up marrying a nurse
that uh was taking care of him at the
asylum or whatever
and um he'd been he'd gotten his [ __ ]
together pretty much
um and he decided though that he's gonna
kill the wife
like he's it's kind of consuming and
because
she got pregnant and he had specifically
told her don't get pregnant because i
have something to matter with me and my
genetics and i don't want to bring a kid
in the world that maybe has
the same problem that i have and she
very sneakily and this was kind of
shitty for her to do i have to
say um kind of stopped taking the pill
without telling him yeah so she could
get pregnant like kind of oh
accidentally um which like i said don't
do that to people that's shitty but uh
but yeah so she did that and he found
out about it and then he got mad and
he's
so he had he's called a radio talk show
uh program yeah hosted by cch pounder
who i wish she had been in more movies
maybe she was in a lot of movies but she
was like
she was perfect to play a radio dj
because she has that great [ __ ]
voice she was in she was in several
horror movies yeah i feel like she was
i have to go and look at her filmography
because i feel like i saw her a lot i
was like oh she's in a bunch of work and
then i
but i couldn't remember what other ones
that she had been in like right around
that time period
or jacob's ladder maybe or something
like yeah but was it
[ __ ] man i can't remember but yeah so
she played the thing so
they were doing a show about mother
killers and he calls in and starts
talking about it he's like hey hey
and then he yeah and then they go back
in a flashback so henry thomas
uh plays him as a young kid and like i
said youngsters nowadays probably know
henry thomas
from uh haunting of hill house on
netflix and haunting a blind manner he
was in that as well
uh but this was when he was really
really young like a teenager and he
plays like a young norman bates and like
i said earlier
olivia hussey hussey plays his
psychotic mother yeah holy crap
you can totally totally see why he ended
up the way he
ended up she's like four characters in
one with a mom like that she is [ __ ]
she's over here and she's over here she
is something else yeah
so you know he doesn't know where the
[ __ ] to go blind exactly and
and like you said there's this weird
sexual it's not even an undercurrent
it's a [ __ ]
current it's it's it's a current it's
right there in your face it's like
they're just
you know she's talking about his dick
and they're rolling around on the floor
together
and then she gets mad like they she does
it and then she laughs and then she's
like what are you doing you filthy
little
yeah yeah yeah bastard and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
and uh so i have to say that you know
like i said i'm not advocating just
murdering people and [ __ ] but
the way that her and her boyfriend
because she gets a boyfriend later on
she'll like oh yeah we're gonna get
married and he's gonna run the hotel and
blah blah
and he was a bit he was a douche too
yeah and then
just the way that both of them talked to
norman yeah
um well was just and then finally he's
like he's like
[ __ ] these mother i'm just gonna poison
their asses well you know that's
something that you know that
a lot of homicides happen every year
everywhere okay
the only ones you hear about are the
outliers where this [ __ ] was [ __ ]
bizarre
yeah most of those homicides are kind of
understandable when you hear what
happens doesn't mean it's not a homicide
it doesn't mean it's not hurt
murder just that's not that interesting
yeah because if you were in the same
situation you're like
yeah asshole's fighting over some chicks
i might i might have done that
yeah taking on some dude he says [ __ ]
you and blows a dude away just [ __ ] like
that
so like i said you can totally so again
this is another one where
norman is sympathetic because you're
seeing him as a kid you're seeing his
upbringing
you're seeing how [ __ ] up it was and
you can't really
blame him i mean you know like i said
it's not good but i'm saying you can't
really blame
him for the world isn't good you can't
moralize everything yeah for like
poisoning is like
psycho mom the movie's not about
moralizing anything it's just about
showing it
yeah and there's a lot of abuse and just
exploring his
his psychosis i guess but in a way that
like i said it doesn't
it it doesn't say oh it's okay that he
did that it's just saying this is why he
did that and you can understand why he
did that
and um like you said at the end of the
series i like that they ended it where
he kind of comes up to a point where his
wife
who he's like i said he says through the
whole movie that he's gonna kill her
and they go back to the house and he is
gonna kill her but then
she basically comes back to him she's
like i trust you not to kill me like
we've
we've worked through all this you don't
have to do it you know if
and then she says something very
interesting too because she's like you
know if we have this baby
she's like well i count for something
too it's like i'm a good person i didn't
kill anybody it's like maybe
you know maybe the kid will take after
me and it'll be fun but you know
that's not what she says but it's
essentially like that so she's like you
know you have to give it a chance you
have to like have hope that things are
going to work out better
and in the end he actually does redeem
himself but he kind of overcomes it
by overcoming his urge to kill him
because he didn't kill anybody and
he didn't kill anybody in the fourth one
did he no because the wife was the only
one that he was going to kill yeah he
was going to do it but then he talked to
him and she
he talked himself out of it with her
help yeah yeah basically
and then i liked that at the very very
end like right after they faded a black
like right before the credits come up
you hear a baby crying
yeah so i was like i guess they left
that there just in case they wanted to
do
you know psycho the next generation or
whatever
it's like the baby norman people get now
a bunch of people get killed in part
four but it's in the past it's in the
flashback
yeah yeah i mean somebody gets killed in
all the movies but it's it's
interesting how few times like you said
it's actually norman doing it
well well it's actually norman in his
own persona
yeah i mean a lot of people get killed
with him dressed up like mom
especially in the third one yeah but you
know other than that yeah like you said
i think i can only remember him being
himself
i think at least two people no four his
mom
also and the boyfriend yeah yeah yeah
that's right but he did that in the past
that was in the past so he killed four
and he was a minor at that time
so they they he wouldn't have been
convicted as an adult anyway
that's true he was a kid that's true and
maybe i don't know if you could do it
back then
probably could have got off because of
the because of the extenuating
circumstance that's what i was going to
say because i mean that's gotta count
for something
they might still put you in a hospital
and [ __ ] but right i do feel like that
but yeah so other than that he killed
emma spool
at the end of two who was that old bat
that came to the house that worked at
the diner with him and said hey i'm your
real mom
you killed a wannabe rock star and he
killed that guy but that guy was a dick
yeah he was trying to kill him at the
time yeah yeah they were fighting it
wasn't like it was a car yeah
it wasn't like a um you know a thing but
now he was gonna kill the nun
girl if she hadn't been laying in there
with her throat with her wrists all
slashed he would have killed her
but it just kind of happened no he was
in his mom's form
oh yeah that's right the mom was going
to do it and that was yeah when the mom
saw it left his it left the body and it
just left norman standing there yeah
why am i wearing this
[Laughter]
yeah but yeah so i'm really really glad
like i said that you guys picked uh for
us to discuss these movies i know it's
like i don't want to go too much into
you know all the technical details and
[ __ ] like that but oh i will say that uh
anthony perkins
has a son if you didn't know named oz
perkins who is also
a horror director in his own right he
has directed
uh i am the pretty thing that lives in
the house he directed the black coat's
daughter he directed gretel and hansel
he's done a you know a few other ones
that we saw yeah yeah okay yeah
i've seen all three of those yeah we
reviewed that movie i said i liked the
movie
i wish there was just more of that witch
in it yeah
i yeah i kind of wish that i would have
gotten rid of the hansel and the gretel
and hansel
it's like let's just have the movie
about the women
let's just watch the witches the witch
[Laughter]
i think i'd headed that thing edited
down to about 70 percent which
you know what i mean we'll always need
more witch yeah just a bunch of [ __ ]
witches
but his other two movies like i said uh
i am the pretty thing and the black
coats daughter
are are excellent like if you really
like those cool like really creepy slow
burn type of [ __ ] he's really into that
um and i really really like this too i
liked those two a lot better than gretel
i liked gretel and hansel sorry but i
liked the other two like a lot better
um but yeah so he's uh kind of carrying
on
uh the work or whatever because as i
said you know anthony perkins died a
while back
but yeah so i'm really glad you guys
picked this one because i can't believe
we haven't talked about psycho because
it's such a [ __ ] classic but that's
probably why
but then you know when i got it's weird
because we were talking i don't even
remember why we were talking about
psycho but
you know before christmas sometime and i
was like oh look they have this
you know the four volume set and i
haven't seen all four movies in such a
long time i'd seen all of them at
various times on cable i wasn't sure but
as i watched them i've seen them all
yeah they didn't remember but i didn't
remem i remembered the first one
obviously i remember two
and i remembered four i didn't remember
three like what happened but then when
we started watching it i it all came
back to me
and i remembered like bits of dialogue
and everything yeah i really remembered
seeing part two
and liking it i think i saw two the most
the other two i remember seeing them and
nev didn't remember
disliking them so i just remembered that
they were probably okay
seeing them seeing them these past
couple days ago no they're all real good
real good yeah they are totally all
worth watching it's like there there's
not a
there's not a dud in the bunch that's
like one of the best four movie
or that's one of the best series for for
horror i'll put that right there with oh
yeah big time
right there with uh phantasm which
phantasm is a great series there isn't a
weak movie in phantasm i loved every
single phantasm movie yeah and
you can't say that for what is there
five of them yeah and you can't
you can't really say that for halloween
you know uh i liked it up until three
past three and then i didn't really and
three doesn't even really count as part
of the series because
it's its own thing right and one and two
friday the 13th and uh really you're
kind of only looking like the [ __ ]
first four or three four
and then after that the fifth one was
good no the fourth one which one was
final chapter
i don't know that one was good they're
fun for you know for what they are for
what they are but they're kind of very
same
yeah psycho is uh kind of a cut above in
terms of quality and acting and just
atmospherics but it still gives you some
slasher scenes
it's good yeah and they like i said they
do something different each time
two and three are kind of similar but
they you know
three kind of expands it out a little
bit because there's a lot more
characters
there and the same actors so you have to
worry about people playing
norman that aren't normal that aren't
norman
same locations or at least it seems to
be the same location every
well it is but everything is a set like
that um
the thing about it is the house
obviously is on the universal back lot
they i think what they did is they it
was at one place in the back lot but
they ended up like taking the whole
house down and moving it
to another place on the back lot so but
but they found
for interestingly for the second one
they found a [ __ ] ton of props
from the original movie so a lot of the
[ __ ] that's in the house was the same
[ __ ] that was in the first one because
they found it yeah
and um also they had to rebuild the
hotel
um because the the hotel from the first
one had been destroyed
so for the second movie they just
rebuild it exactly the same
and then in the background they just did
map paintings because
you know in real life you can see like
the rest of the universal backlot
you know what i mean like behind and um
interestingly too i think in part two
when they go in the town which i think
was called fairvale or whatever it's
called
i think it's a fictional town in
california and um when they go in the
town
i'm pretty sure that's the same square
that they used in like back to the
future and all that other kind of stuff
so
so it's all a set everything is on a set
well the versions we have here all four
movies the
scores all great 10. edits
the edits on all of them are tight there
isn't any bad edits on any of them
they're
they're all product of their time but
they're all like cut top notch for their
time
so i give that 10 out of 10 also acting
acting's pretty much 10 out of 10. it's
to meet a certain tone
that each movie was looking for just i
just no no complaints you know i mean
just
excellent excellent series every single
one of them is enjoyable i
i think i forgot to mention that mick
garris directed the fourth one so that's
why so you had alfred hitchcock richard
franklin
anthony perkins and yeah uh what what i
just said mick garris yeah like directed
all so you got like you know
kind of heavy hitters and like i said
the second one was written by tom
holland who went on to do fright night
and child's play yeah
the perkins direction and movie three is
good too
it's not that you know what i mean the
reason why it falls on the bottom of
them is
because all the other ones are just so
strong it's not a weak movie
[ __ ] real strong i mean i have i have
some people might even switch the order
that's just yeah
and just to taste it's not yeah it's not
one of those things where
obviously one of them is like a million
times better than the other ones and
like you're gonna fight people if they
don't like those
i mean any of these if you put these in
any order i would not be good i would
not be if
you're ordering them to taste yeah
they're all real good
they're all excellent yeah i think so as
well so like i said i'm really glad that
i got you that set
like the only thing like i said the only
shitty thing is they have zero
zero extras and i'm talking nothing yeah
i'd like to have
on any of them making of would be good
or maybe like visiting with some of the
surviving actors all that [ __ ]
with stories what happened and all that
would that would have made it a lot
better but hey that's
they don't have it yeah they just i mean
[ __ ] i watched on youtube i can't
remember the name of the channel but
some guy on uh
youtube did like an hour and 15 minute
retrospective on
the second one mostly but he talked
about the first one and stuff too and it
was like really good it was like really
informative
um so i don't know if he's done it for
all the other ones as well but
cinemassacre did
one talking about all four of them but
it's pretty brief like he just kind of
goes through each one and they say the
same thing we're saying that's pretty
much
um that he was like he said the same
thing where three was probably his least
favorite
but they were all good and they're all
worth watching so you know
um but yeah so check it out this little
psycho collection
i'll put it in the uh i'll put it in our
amazon storefront if you want to get it
like i said if you want extras you
probably got to get them somewhere else
but it's nice having all four movies and
the transfers are nice and everything
like that
so uh that'll do it for this
retrospective four whole movies in one
show
you guys got extra [ __ ] we'll see you on
the next one
bye